every leader of civilization
was built off the back of slaves
replicants of the future but I could
only make so many I worked with the
young man in Los Angeles named Chris and
he lost his sight at a very young age
and he was my teacher but for me it just
it helped create an illusion it was an
experiment that I think really fostered
a world that was important to be in but
you know working with Harrison Ford I'm
kind of glad I had the contacts in
because I you know it was it may be a
little bit more comfortable and that
ease I could hear that voice that
booming voice of his but I think if I
saw my partner to lost my mind how did
your job once
I know what do you want I think the
number one reason to see Blade Runner
20:49 is when the lights go out in the
theater this film takes you to a place
that you've never been it surprises you
it delights you it scares you it's a
sexy film it's a film that makes you
think it's provocative they don't make
movies like this too often so this is
this is one to see in the theater in
IMAX if you can and experience it and
it's all its cinematic glory we were
being hunted maybe who they know you're
here